bonjour à tous merci de nous rejoindre
en direct sur public sénat et en direct
du sénat dans un quart d'heure vous
allez pouvoir suivre sur notre antenne
les questions d'actualité au
gouvernement beaucoup de questions
aujourd'hui qui sont des suites à la
sphère jérôme cahuzac également une
interpellation du groupe communiste sur
les réponses à apporter à la crise
économique et puis des questions sur les
paradis fiscaux la lutte contre
l'évasion fiscale
on va voir tout ça en direct sur notre
antenne dans un quart d'heure mais tout
de suite alain vidalis le ministre
chargé des relations avec le parlement
est avec nous sur ce plateau bonjour
bonjour bonjour
philippe marini le président de la
commission des finances du sénat et
gilles carez président la commission des
finances de l'assemblée nationale vont à
bercy cet après midi pour vérifier les
informations de valeurs actuelles
ce journal publie des infos selon
lesquelles pierre moscovici le ministre
des finances aurait été au courant
depuis le début du mois de décembre
aurait même lancé une enquête sur la
sphère jérôme cahuzac dès début décembre
pardon après les informations de
mediapart oui d'abord sur l'information
elle-même de valeurs actuelles le père
moscovici a démenti totalement démenti
faut quand même le préciser en disant
que ça n'avait aucune consistance et
qu'il allait probablement donner les
suites judiciaires nécessaires quant aux
démarches faites par les présidents des
commissions des finances le rapporteur
du budget ils ont parfaitement le droit
évidemment c'est dans le cadre de
l'heure de la fonction et le
gouvernement entend sur cette affaire
jouer la transparence puisque il y aura
une commission d enquête parlementaire
et je pense qu'il vaut mieux une
commission d enquête parlementaire que
les vociférations que l'on entend ici ou
là notamment à l'assemblée nationale
mais les présidents des commissions des
finances de l'assemblée nationale et du
sénat peuvent obtenir sur place à bercy
tous les documents ils ont le droit
ces pouvoirs
en obligeant un droit particulier qui
est un pouvoir vérifier sur pièces un
certain nombre de choses
ils vont l'exercer et c'est tout à fait
normal pas de commentaire à faire
jérôme cahuzac depuis deux jours d'ici
quelques informations sur sur sa vie
depuis depuis qu'il a quitté le
gouvernement il s'estime traqué il
n'exclut pas non plus toujours son
retour à l'assemblée nationale
vous n'avez aucun moyen de l'empêcher de
revenir à l'assemblée juridiquement non
puisqu'il a le droit de revenir
moralement je pense que c'est tout à
fait impossible
c'est à lui de décider il a pas rendez
vous avec les parlementaires il a rendez
vous avec ses juges il a une date fixe
au sein de laquelle il a fabriqué sa
décision jean luc mélenchon n'en finit
plus de critiquer le gouvernement il
parle aujourd'hui d'un gouvernement à la
ramasse
alors que plusieurs ministres ont
critiqué ces derniers jours la politique
menée en matière économique est ce que
vous lui répondez à jean luc mélenchon
heureusement que vous me préciser que
c'est lui parce que entendre cette
formule a comme celle qu'il utilise ces
derniers jours
j'y mettrai pas forcément comme auteur
jean luc mélenchon compte tenu de son
histoire donc vous mettriez qui va
coûter cd poids des mots qui sont
prononcés par des opposants voire par
des opposants extrêmes donc responsable
a coûté parfois il ya de la confusion
effectivement entre les thématiques
qu'ils utilisent le tous pourris c'est
pas normalement dans la voix d'un
responsable de gauche co longtemps ses
propos le pen fait son jeu je ne
confonds pas il a une histoire
mais justement je préfèrerais qu'il soit
fidèle à son histoire que d'utiliser les
termes qu'il utilise aujourd'hui mais
sur les lignes divergentes au sein du
gouvernement sur la ligne montebourg qui
s'oppose à celle de la ligne du premier
ministre est ce que ça peut durer
longtemps encore au sein du gouvernement
n'y a pas de lignes à l'intérieur du
gouvernement le président de la
république l'a rappelé il n'y a qu'une
politique économique et c'est cette
politique économique qui sera menée
maintenant que y ait des interrogations
le président de la république lui-même a
bien rappelé notamment sur la question
de la politique économique et notamment
de la politique européenne
y avait aujourd'hui nécessité de ne pas
s'enfermer dans l'austérité comme étant
un horizon indépassable
mais qu'il y avait de la rigueur parce
que c'était un passage obligé mais que
l'objectif c'était bien celui qui était
l'objectif du candidat françois hollande
et quels objectifs du président la
république c'est à dire le retour à la
croissance mais ce que les
interrogations les états d'âme des
ministres être publiques les états d'âme
les états d'âme et les interrogations et
arnaud montebourg mais aussi cécile
duflot il ya eu benoît hamon cette si
vous regardez bien les questions qu'ils
posent peut-être avec un peu plus de
tonicité c'est aussi des questions qui
peuvent s'intégrer dans ce qu'a dit le
président de la république lui-même et
ce qui compte c'est la parole du
président de la république débat ici au
sénat s'éternise autour du projet loi
mariage pour tous alors que la situation
économique et sociale des français
devient de plus en plus urgente est ce
que c'est bien raisonnable de
privilégier ce genre de texte au
parlement
je ne vois pas ce qui nous obligerait à
choisir entre le social et le sociétal
il y à un texte c'est pas nous c'est les
français qui sont dans des situations
très précaires et qui préférait qu'on
choisit des solutions sociales plutôt
que sociétal
elle a écouté à ce moment là il suffit
de renvoyer la question à ceux qui font
durer le débat ici père plutôt le débat
sur cette question que vous avez l'air
de considérer comme une petite important
sera terminée plutôt apprécié dit que ce
n'était peut-être pas l'urgence mais ça
c'est possible mais dans tous les cas
plutôt ça sera fini plus tôt on passera
aux textes sur la sécurisation de
l'emploi qui est un texte social un
texte sur le pouvoir dans l'entreprise
un texte qui intéresse des salariés qui
aujourd'hui n'ont pas de droit je parle
notamment aux mutuelles et donc c'est le
texte qui viendra prochainement au sénat
que l'on regarde vers ce texte là je le
souhaite aussi carrément milieu de
semaine au sénat effectivement ce texte
selon vous selon vos calculs qu'on va
intervenir le vote définitif sur le
projet de loi mariage ici au sénat à
vendredi samedi
peut-être peut-être cette nuit les
sénateurs exercent leurs droits il n'y a
pas de pouvoir de contrainte au delà des
textes réglementaires donc ça sera ouste
nuit où la nuit prochaine ou ou la nuit
d'après dans tous les cas que le débat
aille jusqu'au bout et que personne ne
sorte de ce débat net en france le
gouvernement les
le débat aller jusqu'au bout parce qu'il
sanaa depuis hier sur la possibilité que
le gouvernement utilise l'article 44-3
le vote bloqué sur une partie du texte
notamment sur les articles additionnels
qui ont été renvoyés à la fin la
discussion mais le vote bloqué c'est pas
c'est une procédure parlementaire ça
n'empêche pas le hockey rarissime akira
origines je ne crois pas qu'elle a été
utilisée c'était lors du sexe ici c'est
une disposition assez mal vécue par les
parlementaires quand le gouvernement
c'est une disposition constitutionnelle
qui n'est pas utilisé à priori qui est
aujourd'hui dans le débat mais comme
vous le dis j'ai si les choses ne
deviennent impossibles si le calendrier
n'est pas tenue il faut pas l'exclure
mais dans tous les cas c'est pas à
l'heure où on parle l'état d'esprit du
gouvernement
non mais il se pourrait en tout cas que
vous disiez cette arme si ça traîne ça
ne veut pas dire comme a renoncé à
exercer des possibilités que la
constitution nous donne et qui ne sont
loin d'être exceptionnelles il ya de
plus en plus de textes de projet de loi
aux propositions de lois qui sont
annoncés un peu comme prioritaires on
sent un encombrement parlementaire
majeur alain vidalis vous qui êtes
chargé des relations avec le parlement
comment vous en sortez quelles vont être
les les grands textes quelles sont vos
priorités d'ici l'été
le texte se sont annoncés je partage
avec vous l'idée qu' on a du mal quand
même à tenir le calendrier d'ici l'été
non non on va le tenir nous allons ce
sujet nous allons siéger jusqu'au 26
juillet par rapport aux textes qui sont
en cours et aux textes annoncé n'allons
pas faire de tri et nous aurons la
possibilité sans rajouter d'autres
textes sauf celui sur la transparence et
quand même l'initiative récente et
importante du président de la république
l'ensemble de ces textes devraient
pouvoir être examinés dans le calendrier
jusqu'à la fin juillet et vous maintenez
un congrès à la fin du mois de juillet
ça c'est une décision qui appartient au
président de la république elle est
assez vraisemblable puisque dans le
circuit il y à des réformes
constitutionnelles et notamment une
importante dans le climat d'aujourd'hui
qu'est la réforme du conseil supérieur
de la magistrature
mais vous dites assez vraisemblable
c'est une décision du président de la
république donc je ne peux pas
marc augé ce pouvoir mais vous avez
compris que c'est une quasi certitude
quant à la loi sur la moralisation de la
vie publique quand va-t-elle venir en
examen au parlement elle vient en
concert devant le conseil des ministres
le 24 avril
voilà la date n'est pas totalement fixé
mais aux environs du lieu du 20 mai ce
texte devrait être examiné devant
l'assemblée nationale et ensuite au
sénat
est-ce que vous pensez que les mesures
qui ont été annoncées par le chef de
l'état cette semaine vont suffire à
restaurer la confiance vis-à-vis des
français
est ce qu'elles vont suffire à restaurer
la confiance je pense qu'on a une
question qu est une question préalable
c'est restaurer la capacité d' écoute
des français par rapport à la parole
publique c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui il
y a scepticisme une suspicion même
parfois vis-à-vis de la classe politique
et donc je crois qu'il faut bien s'en de
17% des voix là c'est qu'ils pensent que
les délais sont plus ou moins qu'on pût
exactement et ça correspond en rien à la
réalité et donc qu'il ya un passage
obligé
c'est de restaurer il faut bien
comprendre que c'est ça ça passe par une
transparence absolue
si les français ont cette suspicion
répondants le c'est notre responsabilité
et notre responsabilité aujourd'hui
c'est de rétablir au moins cette
capacité d'écouté et j'ai envie vraiment
d'attirer l'attention de tout le monde
c'est pas une question simplement pour
le gouvernement ou pour la majorité
c'est une question pour toutes
tous les responsables des partis
politiques républicains mais certains y
compris dans votre camp je pense
évidemment à claude bartolone le
président de l'assemblée nationale qui
n'aime pas tellement cette terre de
soupçon généralisé
pour lui cet excès de transparence
renforce au contraire le soupçon qu'est
ce que vous lui répondez
je pense que si aujourd'hui parce que il
y aurait le risque de cet excès des
excès de transparence ont renoncé où on
ne répondait pas la suspicion
alors pour le coup on pourrait prendre
le risque et j'ai envie de dire de
continuer à parler dans le vide c'est ça
le problème qui est posé aujourd'hui oui
mais lui il a peur que par ces mesures
on jette je reprends ce propos les
députés en pâture les politiques doivent
payer finalement pour les excès pour la
fraude d'un seul homme
enfin la transparence la transparence
simplement dire quel est l'état des du
patrimoine alors que les français se
posent se pose des questions et je crois
qu'aujourd'hui puisqu'on le sait on sait
qu'il ya cette suspicion
alors il faut y apporter des réponses
rien ne serait pire que de rester
spectateur
par rapport à une opinion publique qui
en fait n'écoute plus aujourd'hui les
responsables politiques quels qu'ils
soient
est-ce qu'on va aussi vers
l'interdiction de certains mandats avec
le cumul de profession et lesquelles
c'est aussi pas tout le monde à l'esprit
le fait que c'est peut-être pas tout à
fait normal qu'un parlementaire ça en
même temps
avocat d'affaires lié à un certain
nombre de situations auxquelles
aujourd'hui il faudrait il faut répondre
parce qu'elles nourrissent la suspicion
dont on a parlé tout à l'heure
donc c'est ça l'objectif mais ce cas pas
un risque aussi d'uniformisation du
corps de métier d'origine des
parlementaires on a vu par exemple ici
en vingt ans au sénat on est passé d'une
proportion de 20% de sénateurs
fonctionnaires à 50% aujourd'hui est ce
que tous les élus parlementaires vont
être des fonctionnaires
je ne connais pas la statistique précise
pour le sénat mais l'assemblée nationale
elle est plutôt dans l'autre sens donc
c'est pas en faire choisir que des
fonctionnaires et il y aura des gens qui
continueront à pouvoir exercer leur
métier mais les métiers sur lesquels il
y a potentiellement un conflit d'intérêt
chacun le comprend bien
ces métiers là ne peuvent pas être
exercés enfin être parlementaire c'est
un métier à plein temps que certains
puissent continuer parce que c'est leur
activité qu'il faudra bien qu'il la
fasse après avoir cet exercice
professionnel
naturellement c'est vrai mais on peut
être avocat d'affaires avant avocat
d'affaires après pas nécessairement le
mon point de vue de notre point de vue
pendant le mandat
le cumul la limitation du cumul des
mandats c'est l'andra quand on examens
ici au sénat et à l'assemblée nationale
da définitive est pas fixée mais plutôt
début juin ici au sénat très bien
m'écouter merci beaucoup à alain vidalis
d'être venu en direct sur notre antenne
je voulais c'est rejoindre l'hémicycle
du sénat puisque dans quelques instants
effectivement nous allons suivre les
questions d'actualité au gouvernement
avant de suivre cette séance nous allons
retrouver delphine girard notre
journaliste qui se trouve dans la
tribune de presse d'el feel puisqu'après
les questions de l'actuelle bien
reprendra le texte le projet de loi sur
le mariage pour tous
faites nous un petit point où on en est
ou sur ce texte ici bien les débats
s'enlisent toujours un perrine puisque
ce matin et bien après une semaine de
discussions les sénateurs aborde
seulement vont seulement aborder cet
après midi à l'article 4 de ce projet de
loi qui en compte 23
alors il faut dire que les esprits
s'échauffent en corse
il ya eu un incident de séance entre le
sénateur ump de la vendée bruno
retailleau et la sénatrice écologiste du
val de marne
esther benbassa nous n'avons pas les
mêmes couleurs politiques d'ailleurs
nous n'avons pas d'autres couleurs n'ont
plus en commun a lancé bruno retailleau
à l'adresse d'esther benbassa rappel au
règlement de jean-vincent placé le
président du groupe écologiste vous fait
de la provocation idéologique at il
lancé
il y à une suspension de séance bruno de
retard you c'est à demi mot excuse et il
a dit qu'il parlait en fait de la
couleur des cheveux d'esther benbassa
enfin tout cela signifie quand même
qu'il ya une certaine tension qui règne
ici depuis le début de l'examen de ce
projet de loi il faut dire et bien que
la droite use de toutes les procédures
parlementaires pour retarder les débats
il ya d'abord eu lieu quatre motions
puis des rappels au règlement
puis démultiplication de prise de parole
à chaque fois qu'il y a des articles qui
sont discutées ou encore de nombreuses
explications de vote des suspensions de
séance et puis encore ce matin pour la
quatrième fois consécutive et bien la
droite a demandé la vérification du
quorum alors tout cela crée un certain
climat de tension alors est-ce que et
bien la gauche va souhaiter va souhaiter
bien raccourcir les débats a priori le
groupe socialiste s'est réuni ce matin
il souhaite laisser libre cours et bien
au débat en tous les cas votre invité le
ministre en charge des relations avec le
parlement
et peut-être moins sûr il y aura
peut-être un vote bloqué en tous les cas
on verra bien ce qu'il en est tout à
l'heure à la reprise des débats c'est à
16h15 en attendant bénigne je pense que
les questions d'actualité au
gouvernement vont débuter
merci delphine effectivement je le
disais tout à l'heure de trois questions
qui font suite à la sphère jérôme
cahuzac avec des ris avec notamment des
questions autour de la lutte contre
l'évasion fiscale également une
interpellation du groupe communiste sur
les réponses à apporter à la crise
on va tout de suite dans l'hémicycle
pour suivre en direct ces questions
d'actu on se retrouve après ici avec nos
invités tout al'air question de même que
là où le ministre pour sa réponse
dispose j'assiste chacun de deux minutes
trente
la parole est à monsieur andré gattolin
pour le groupe écologiste
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
président madame la ministre mes chers
collègues
madame la ministre le président de la
république effectuera son premier voyage
officiel en chine les 25 et 26 avril
prochains
nous nous disposerons pas encore d'un
ordre du jour précis mais il semblerait
que ce déplacement vise notamment à
stimuler les relations commerciales
entre nos deux pays
de fait ce sont des enjeux importants
mais il ne doit cependant pas en nous du
coup on occulte et d'autres en
particulier ceux qui se rapportent au
respect des libertés civiles et des
droits humains auxquels notre pays a
toujours été très attaché à ce sujet et
sans réduire la question des libertés en
chine à ce seul point la situation
actuelle du tibet est particulièrement
préoccupante depuis février 2009 112
tibétains se sont immolés par le feu
pour protester contre les atteintes
graves aux droits humains au tube est ce
décompte macabre évolue malheureusement
de jour en jour il traduit le désespoir
absolu d'un peuple qui refuse de voir sa
culture et son avenir annihiler depuis
de nombreux mois
l'accès à cette région est totalement
fermée aux étrangers qu'il s'agisse de
diplomates d'organisations humanitaires
de journalistes ou de simples voyageurs
inquiets de cette situation le sénat à
l'initiative de son groupe d'information
sur le tibet adoptée le 27 novembre
dernier une résolution relative à
l'action européenne en faveur de la
protection des droits au tibet cette
résolution met notamment l'accent sur un
recours disproportionné à la force face
aux manifestations au tibet et sur
l'impasse actuelle des pourparlers entre
le gouvernement chinois et les
émissaires du dalaï lama
elle demande aussi aux hauts
représentants de l'union européenne pour
les affaires étrangères et la politique
de sécurité de confier au représentant
spécial de l'union pour les droits de
l'homme monsieur lambrinidis un mandat
pour faire de la question tibétaine une
priorité de son action
la france n'est pas la seule à se
préoccuper ainsi de la situation et
plusieurs autres pays ont également voté
des résolutions allant dans le même sens
cette semaine lors d'un voyage officiel
en chine la première ministre
australienne n'a pas manqué d'exprimer
auprès du président xi jingping sa vive
préoccupation quant au respect des
droits de l'homme en chine et au tibet
en particulier ma question madame la
ministre porte donc sur tours à point
précis premièrement le président de la
république canton il lui aussi évoqué
avec son homologue chinois la question
des droits de l'homme en chine et à
l'intérieur du tibet deuxièmement le
président est il favorable à une
médiation européenne telle que proposée
par la résolution du sénat
enfin le président françois hollande
envisage-t-il dans un avenir proche de
recevoir le dalaï lama en france ou à
tout le moins monsieur lobsang sangay
premier ministre de l'administration du
tibet en exil je vous remercie
merci la parole à madame najat
vallaud-belkacem les listes des droits
des femmes porte parole du gouvernement
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur les
sénateurs d'abord je vous prie d'excuser
l'absence de laurent fabius retenue à la
réunion des ministres du g8 à londres
monsieur le sénateur la vague
d'immolations qui a été observé en effet
depuis le printemps 2011 maintenant dans
les régions de peuplement tibétain en
chine suscite partout dans le monde
beaucoup d'émotion et de tristesse
la france à cet égard s'est exprimé
publiquement à plusieurs reprises pour
faire part à chaque fois de sa
préoccupation profonde face aux récents
développements pour rattacher pour
rappeler pardon à chaque fois son
attachement au respect des droits de
l'homme son attachement à la liberté de
religion à la liberté de conviction
ainsi qu'à la préservation de la culture
et des traditions tibétaines
la position de la france monsieur le
sénateur et constante en ce domaine
nous considérons
le dialogue entre les autorités
chinoises et le dalaï lama et la voie
pour parvenir à une solution durable qui
respecte à la fois pleinement l'identité
culturelle et spirituelle tibétaine et
en même temps dans le cadre de la
république populaire de chine
le prochain déplacement du président de
la république en chine va être
l'occasion de renforcer notre dialogue
et notre partenariat dans tous les
domaines ce partenariat il est global il
n'oublie aucun sujet il porte sur tous
les thèmes d'intérêt commun et bien
entendu celui des droits de l'homme en
fait partie intégrante dans ce cas dans
sachez qu aucun sujet n'est exclue que
toutes les questions seront abordées
dans un esprit de franchise et de
respect mutuel au niveau européen enfin
monsieur le sénateur la situation des
droits de l'homme en chine en
particulier dans cette dimension
tibétaine est très régulièrement abordée
dans les institutions de l'union
européenne qui s'est d'ailleurs dotée
d'un représentant spécial pour les
droits de l'homme ainsi qu'avec
l'ensemble des états européens
par ailleurs la situation au tibet est
évoquée lors de chaque session du
dialogue euro chinois sur les droits de
l'homme et nous continuerons nous sommes
décidés à le faire notre action sur ce
point de concert avec chacun de nos
partenaires européens
une dernière question que vous posiez
monsieur le sénateur le projet de visite
du dalaï lama en france sachez que pour
le moment nous n'avons pas connaissance
d'un tel projet et je vous remercie
merci merci la parole est à madame
eliane assassi madame la présidente
pour le groupe crc monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les ministres mes
chers collègues une crise politique
grave se déroule dans notre pays
la démission du ministre du budget ses
aveux de malversations ont mis en
évidence l'implication étroite entre la
finance et le domaine public y compris
le champ politique
les sénatrices et les sénateurs
communistes qui avaient déposé il ya
trois ans le 1er juillet 2010 une
proposition de loi constitutionnelle
pour garant dit garantir l'indépendance
du président de la république et des
ministres vis-à-vis du pouvoir
économique approuve sans réserve les
mesures qui permettront d'assurer la
transparence et d'éliminer c'est cela
l'objet l'influencent néfastes des
financiers et lobbys liste sur les choix
politiques
les choix économiques et les choix
sociaux un élu ne doit pas tirer un
profit personnel de sa fonction la
question de la publication des
déclarations de patrimoine et d'intérêts
se pose mais restent à examiner de
quelle manière pour ne pas tomber dans
une surenchère voyeuriste
l'immense majorité des élus qui se
dévouent pour leur population qui
participe au débat politique et
idéologique n'ont rien et n'auront rien
à craindre en la matière mais cela n'est
pas tout les hésitations actuelles
montre bien que l'essentiel est ailleurs
le président de la république en
insistant sur le rôle des banques
la lutte contre les paradis fiscaux a
pointé un fait essentiel c'est le
libéralisme la libre circulation de
l'argent des capitaux qui est source de
dérives qui est source de corruption
trop longtemps trop longtemps nous avons
été les seuls au parti communiste
français au front de gauche avec quelque
part ce personnalité a dénoncé l'argent
roi
l'argent qui corrompt il est temps
aujourd'hui d'affronter le monde de la
finance
cet ennemi sans visage hier dénoncé
mesdames et messieurs les ministres
montrés du doigt les banques est une
bonne chose car celles ci profitent de
la crise vampiriser états et les peuples
mais cela n'est pas suffisant il faut
s'attaquer au système qui organisent
leur action seul un changement de cap en
france comme en europe peut redonner
confiance au peuple et pas seulement
quelques mesures de transparence la
sphère audit cahuzac est un symptôme du
triomphe du libéralisme en europe c'est
la démocratie qui est moralement
atteinte par le pouvoir de l'argent
nous vous demandons d'en prendre
conscience au stop à l'austérité
maquillé en ciel de budgétaire en
mettant fin le cap sur la croissance
la politique industrielle durable et sur
l'emploi trouve ici ministre de
l'économie et des finances monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs madame la sénatrice madame la
présidente eliane assassi je vais
répondre à votre question qui comportait
en fait plusieurs tiroirs avec toutefois
vous le comprendrez une nuance d'emblée
qui est que je ne crois pas et je ne
peux même pas laisser dire ici que nous
sommes devant autre chose que la faute
grave
impardonnable que le mensonge d'un homme
qui ne le symptôme d'aucune autre chose
ce n'est pas le symptôme d'une faute du
gouvernement
ce n'est pas non plus le symptôme du
libéralisme il faut savoir établir les
responsabilités au niveau où elles sont
mais pour le reste cela a créé un choc
incontestablement et c'est à ce choc que
le président la république a voulu hier
répondent par un autre choc un choc de
moralisation et c'est la raison en effet
pour lequel il a souhaité que la
transparence se fassent jour sur les
patrimoines et pas juste la transparence
la transparence et le contrôle à travers
une autorité indépendante présidée par
une personnalité incontestable et pas
seulement la transparence également
aussi la répression
et puis à côté de cela il ya un deuxième
aspect dans votre question qui était la
lutte contre certaines dérives de la
finance nous avons commencé à l'amener
ici
quand nous avons voté ensemble la loi
bancaire qui pour la première fois pour
un pays je ne parle pas seulement pour
la france a fait en sorte que l'on
puisse aller demander aux banques
ce que sont leurs activités ce que et
leur chiffre d'affaires dans tous les
pays du monde y compris dans les paradis
fiscaux et vous savez que le président
n'aurait plus qu'à insisté sur ce point
fortement mais nous voulons aller plus
loin quand j'ai proposé avec mes
homologues allemand italien britannique
espagnol qu'on adapte ce qui existe aux
états unis
pas de casser les changes automatique
d'informations nous allons loin très
loin
enfin il ya un dernier aspect dans votre
question qui est la politique économique
que nous suivons je veux dire ici à tout
le monde à la représentation nationale
au sénat que cette politique
contrairement à ce qui est dit s'il
n'est pas une politique d'austérité
je combats l'austérité je combats
l'austérité en europe car je pense en
effet que si l'europe n'est qu'une
discipline punitive
l'europe ne convaincra pas ces peuples
je ne pratique pas commis de l'économie
et des finances une politique
d'austérité
en france l'autorité du premier ministre
et du président de la république car
c'est une politique qui va au rythme qui
est nécessaire et qui donne les marges
de manoeuvre qui fait jouer les
stabilisateurs automatiques
quand la croissance est fait mais c'est
une politique sérieuse et cette
politique sérieuse elle passe par le
désendettement
il y a un cap comme l'a dit le président
la république hier ce cap c'est le
sérieux ya un objectif qui est la
croissance une exigence qui l'emploie
nous ne dévierons pas merci la parole à
monsieur robert tropéano où le groupe
pse merci monsieur le président monsieur
le président mesdames et messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues la crise
de la vienne de cheval résulte de
l'accumulation d'évolution est
inacceptable au cours de ces dernières
années qui ont aussi conduit les agents
de la direction générale de la
concurrence de la consommation et de la
répression des fraudes à manifester
samedi dernier à paris il faut rappeler
que ces agents n'ont joué un rôle
crucial dans la révélation de ces
fraudes fraude qui témoigne de pratiques
peu scrupuleuses de l'industrie agro
alimentaire mais aussi de carence dans
les réglementations françaises et
européennes
c'est agen font un travail remarquable
qui mérite d'être salué or ils sont
aujourd'hui gagnées par la colère et le
découragement et je crois qu'on peut les
cobras n'a depuis 2007 560 postes ont
été supprimés
résultat les 3000 à jacques qui couvre
aujourd'hui l'ensemble du territoire
national ne peuvent plus assurer
correctement leurs trois missions
essentielles que sont la sécurité des
consommateurs
leur protection économique et la
régulation concurrentielle des marchés
conséquence directe de la diminution
drastique des moyens humains et
financiers
le nombre de contrôles effectués par la
dgccrf est en chute libre
ils ont baissé de 13% en 2012 dans
certains départements le nombre d'agents
a été divisé par plus de trois depuis
2009 pour rappel dans l'aude département
cher à nos collègues courteau irait nom
d'alain deneault où les fraudes dans la
sphère de la viande de cheval ont été
constatés un seul à agen est affecté au
contrôle alimentaire
la réforme de la dgccrf
entré chez en 2008 a de surcroît conduit
à une désorganisation totale des
services
les agents sont désormais répartis entre
les directions régionales des
entreprises de la concurrence de la
consommation du travail de l'emploi et
des directions départementales de la
protection des populations à
l'organigramme est particulièrement
complexe
s'ajoute l'absence d'une mise en réseau
rapide et efficace des informations
cette inertie directement liée à la
nouvelle organisation affaiblie les
conditions d'exercice des agents de la
dgccrf
c'est pourquoi il est indispensable de
leur accorder des moyens supplémentaires
mais aussi un retour à une organisation
plus efficace et plus cohérente
c'est une condition sine qua none pour
permettre à la dgccrf de remplir
pleinement ses missions de service
public
ô combien primordial pour nos
concitoyens alors monsieur le ministre
quelles dispositions comptez vous
prendre pour permettre à la dgccrf de
fonctionner correctement et d'assumer
pleinement ses missions de contrôle et
de protéger si merci la parole benoît
hamon ministre chargé de l'économie
sociale et solidaire et de la
consommation monsieur
le sénateur ce président mesdames et
messieurs je vais essayer de vous
répondre sur les deux plans que vous
évoquez à la fois la nécessité de
renforcer les effectifs de la dgccrf de
façon à ce que ces agents remplissent
correctement leur travail sur le terrain
ils souhaitent en capacité d'effectuer
les contrôles que l'on qu'on leur
demande et en même temps de quelle
manière
aujourd'hui renforcer les pouvoirs de
cette note administration de façon à ce
qu'elle fasse mieux respecter les procès
verbaux qu'elle dresse et les
injonctions qu'elle fait aux différentes
entreprises
la réalité c'est que l' affaire dite de
la viande de cheval a révélé coin elle a
révélé aujourd'hui la réduction des
effectifs sur le terrain présent de la
dgccrf conséquence d'un double mouvement
d'abord la mise en oeuvre assez absurde
de la rgpp qui a amené à ce que durant
les cinq dernières années
hélas 16% des effectifs de la dgccrf ont
été réduits et qu'on a perdu 16% des
effectifs et je le dis parce que on peut
vouloir on peut vouloir avoir une
politique de réduction de la dépense
publique sans pour autant être sot sur
le fait qu' il y a là des choix qui sont
des choix prioritaires que de protéger
les consommateurs contre la tromperie
économique
raison pour laquelle je me réjouis que
le ministre de l'économie des finances
et demandé cette année pour l'année 2013
la stabilisation des effectifs de la
dgccrf
en dépit du fait que cette
administration n'était pas prioritaire
qu'elles étaient toutes amenés à
contribuer pour financer les créations
de postes dans la police gendarmerie et
l'éducation nationale pas la dgccrf nous
avons maintenu les effectifs
nous avons maintenu les effectifs mais
nous devons aussi subir les conséquences
de l'arrêt at c'est à dire
l'organisation territoriale nouvelle que
là encore le précédent gouvernement a
souhaité qui a séparé les missions en
deux niveaux territoriaux distincts et
en même temps deux départementales deux
départements interministériel distincts
résultat nous avons aujourd'hui une
désorganisation des services sur le
terrain une chaîne de commandement qui a
été remise en cause et une baisse je le
dis bien une baisse de 13,5 pour cent
des contrôles sur le terrain
or la commission européenne aujourd'hui
demande ou exil
les services de la dgccrf qu'ils
remplissent de nouvelles missions de
contrôle nous avons nous même voulu que
la filière viande et la filière poisson
soit mise sous surveillance après
laffaire spanghero raison pour laquelle
aujourd'hui nous souhaitons que ses
effectifs soit revue et que
l'organisation territoriale qui sera
mise en oeuvre dans le cadre du 6 maps
tiennent compte des défauts qui ont été
hérités du précédent gouvernement
dernière chaude sur les pouvoirs
je suis content que vous la trouviez ça
fait plaisir vous reconnaissiez un tout
petit peu vos erreurs
le mais je veux terminer sur le fait que
je suis sûr que vous nous soutiendrait
quand il s'agira de renforcer les
pouvoirs de la dgccrf
vous qui êtes toujours champion pour
donner la leçon à tout le monde vous
votre aile projet de loi consommation
pour faire en sorte que demain nous
puissions avoir davantage de sanctions
administratives que l'on punisse les
entreprises qui faute et grâce à vous le
crime en chine seuls merci merci bien
la parole à monsieur philippe marini
pour le groupe ump
monsieur le président du sénat cette
question s'adresse à monsieur pierre
moscovici
monsieur le ministre on nous a fait des
annonces cette semaine dont beaucoup mes
chers collègues monsieur le président
sincèrement il serait préférable que
l'on puisse s'exprimer
pour deux minutes et demie correctement
et avec un minimum d coûte le sud
restaurateurs vous avez deux minutes
trente
je vous en prie allez-y monsieur le
ministre
des annonces ont été faites beaucoup
d'entre nous pensent qu'il s'agit d'une
simple diversion par rapport à une
situation très grave que le gouvernement
n'arrive pas à gérer
je voudrais dire que s'agissant de
lutter contre les excès des paradis
fiscaux
les annonces qui ont été faites sont
excellentes dans leur principe mais
qu'il faut aussi savoir utiliser les
outils qui existent déjà
or à la suite de la crise financière
des réunions du g20 un raison de
conventions internationales s'est
perfectionnée en particulier avec la
suisse
ceux ci donnant lieu à la signature d'un
avenant qui a été postérieurement en
février 2010 est tendue par un échange
de lettres entre les directeurs des
administrations fiscales suisses et
françaises cet échange de lettres vous
aurait permis
monsieur le ministre d'interroger
beaucoup plus largement que vous l'avez
fait l'administration fiscale suisse
pour savoir si oui ou non un certain
docteur cahuzac détenait bien
directement ou indirectement des comptes
en suisse
monsieur le ministre pourquoi avez-vous
quittez votre question de manière
étroite à la seule banque ubs
en second lieu et alors qu'il était de
notoriété publique
monsieur le ministre que d'éventuels
comptes en suisse avait pu être déplacés
vers singapour
pourquoi n'at-on pas utiliser la
convention franco singapourienne qui
remonte à la même époque et qui
permettait de s'assurer auprès de cet
état qu'il y avait eu ou qu'il n'y avait
pas de compte
monsieur le ministre vous avez bien
voulu me répondre par écrit les réponses
qui ont été faites ne me semble pas
épuisé le sujet d'autant que ces
réponses me paraissent aujourd'hui être
éclairée par de nouveaux bruits de
nouvelles rumeurs de nouvelles
indications parues dans la presse qui
probablement s'ils oublient que cet apn
sur n'en est qu'à ses débuts
merci la parole à pierre moscovici
ministre de l'économie et des finances
monsieur le président marini mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs
j'ai lu évidemment j'ai entendu toutes
les questions mais aussi tous les
raccourcis toutes les simplifications
sur ce qu'on appelle la sphère kazakh
je répète ici qu'il s'agit de la faute
du mensonge d'un homme pas d'une
responsabilité collective et prenez
garde à ne pas tomber dans ce type de
dérives je vois ce matin de nouvelles
allégations dans un hebdomadaire à
droite très à droite très très à droite
je veux parler de valeurs actuelles
allégation qui vous conduiront cet après
midi vous êtes le bienvenu à venir au
ministère des finances pour vérifier de
quoi il s'agit mais je veux lire ici
avec la plus grande force la plus grande
fermeté que ces allégations sont
mensongères que je l'élément que les
mensonges les combats et que je me
réserve de nos les suites de tout cela
devant la justice pour le reste je veux
m'en tenir aux faits puisque dans vos
qualités vous m'avez interrogé et c'est
légitime
monsieur le président la commission des
finances
c'est facile de réécrire l'histoire a
posteriori il y avait bien ici ou là des
analyses mais une seule mise en cause
existait c'était celle de médiapart qui
disait que jérôme cahuzac aurait possédé
début 2010 un compte à la banque ubs en
suisse
ensuite transféré à singapour c'est
cette information là et c'est la seule
que l'administration fiscale a cherché à
vérifier à travers une convention
d'entraidé avec la suisse j'ai déjà
répondu sur le champ de notre demande
d'entre elles nous avons interrogé sur
la banque ubs car nous n'avions pas
d'éléments à cette date qui permettait
de viser d'autres établissements
financiers et sur ce point
vous évoquez un avenant mais cet avenant
contrairement à ce que vous dites
il est plus restrictif que la convention
sur ce point là il ne permettait pas
d'évoquer des circonstances ou des
conditions exceptionnelles nous avons
demandé aux autorités suisses
et personne ne l'avait fait avant nous
personne aucun gouvernement de remonter
loin dans le temps jusqu'en 2006 date de
la prescription fiscale
nous avons demandé pour ce qui
concernait non seulement monsieur
cahuzac
mais des ayants droit ça pouvait être
des intermédiaires nous avons demandé
aussi s'il ya eu transfert et sur tous
ces points je dis bien tous ces points
la réponse des autorités suisses elle
est claire nette précise négative alors
je dis qu ensuite tout a été transmis à
qui de droit
d'abord la police judiciaire puisqu'il
est une enquête ensuite quand vous
l'avez demandé à vous même dans votre
qualité de président de la commission
des finances
alors pour terminer mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs permettez moi de
m'adresser à vous un peu personnellement
dans cette affaire
l'administration fiscale a fait tout ce
qu'elle pouvait elle a fait tout ce
qu'elle devait dans le respect du droit
et c'est fondamental
elle était comme toujours remarquable
honnête vigoureuse rigoureuse et prenons
garde a ici le transformer la faute d'un
homme en attaque contre un gouvernement
comptera ministres intègres à ne pas
salir cette administration qui est une
des plus capable du monde une des plus
compétentes que je suis fier aujourd'hui
de diriger avec bernard cazeneuve
merci monsieur
monsieur le président si vous le voulez
vous savez ce phoque le disais il n'est
pas de choses plus blessante qu'un
reproches injustes mais quand on a rien
à se reprocher on affronte les reproches
avec fermeté c'est ce que je fais merci
la parole ma mère me nathalie goulet
pour le groupe
udi plus est
merci la parole à madame boulet oui
monsieur le président mesdames messieurs
les ministres mes chers collègues ma
question s'adresser au premier ministre
mais ce sera monsieur moscovici qui me
répondra en mars dernier le sénat a fait
la demande du groupe crc qu'il faut
remercier sous la présidence de philippe
dominati et grâce à éric bocquet
excellent rapporteur un travail
absolument remarquable de plus de 2000
pages sur un rapport d'information sur
l'évasion et la fraude fiscale nos
auditions ont été largement médiatisés
nul ne pouvait ignorer ses conclusions
et 60 et une propositions préconisées
pour lutter contre la fraude fiscale
l'évasion fiscale la lutte contre les
territoires non coopératifs et donc les
paradis fiscaux
c'est ainsi que certains d'entre nous
ont tenté pendant le projet de loi de
finances rectificative d'insérer
quelques dispositions puis pendant le
projet de loi de finances toujours sans
succès et que lors des débats que nous
avons eus le 3 octobre dernier dans le
cadre de la procédure de contrôle
c'est madame escoffier remarquable
ministre qui était au banc prog peuvent
sans doute de l'intérêt que bercy porte
à nos travaux
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui aujourd'hui la
sphère cahuzac créer un climat de mcc
artistes qu'il faut qu'il ne faut à
aucun prix alimentée par des mesures
prises sous le coup de l'émotion
la question de la fraude fiscale
amalgamer à celle de la moralisation de
la vie publique crée un climat délétère
regrettable à l'égard de tous les élus
qui dans leur très grande majorité ont
le sens de l'état de l'intérêt général
et dont l'activité il faut le savoir est
déjà très encadrée
ce qui n'est pas le cas des banques de
certaines banques de certaines
entreprises y compris celles dont l'état
est actionnaire qui elle use et abuse de
paradis fiscaux et de schémas
d'optimisation fiscale en toute impunité
les annonces du président de la
république de ce point de vue vont dans
le bon sens
ma question est simple monsieur le
ministre est légitime
si on prend en considération le travail
accompli par notre haute assemblée est
en même temps le degré de frustration
que nous avons tous les membres de cette
commission denquête de voir notre
travail négligée
pourquoi n'avez vous pas pris depuis le
mois de juillet le temps de mettre en
application certaines mesures beaucoup
d'entre elles sont du domaine
réglementaire de bon sens et peu
onéreuse
le projet de loi annoncé pour le 24
avril va arriver pouvez vous nous donner
des détails nous assurer qu'il prendra
en compte le travail de notre route a
semblé marquant ainsi une volonté forte
d'endiguer ce fléau qu'est l'évasion
fiscale sans merci merci monsieur pierre
moscovici
madame la sénatrice nathalie goulet
je vous remercie de ne pas contribuer au
climat que vous appelez mct artistes qui
peut régner ici ou là je m'associe
également aux compliments que vous
faites à madame escoffier comme ministre
et aux sénateurs éric bocquet qui a fait
avec monsieur dominati un travail
absolument remarquable le premier
ministre sont nés entretenu ce matin
avec les élus communistes et de tout
cela je veux dire que nous tirons des
leçons
il n'est pas exact de dire que le
gouvernement n'a pas agi mais il est
vrai de dire qu'il agira encore plus
fort dans les temps qui viennent pour
renforcer les outils contre l'évasion
fiscale
d'abord rappelé que nous avons fait et
qui va dans le sens de vos propositions
dans la loi de finances rectificative de
la fin de l'année dernière nous avons
pris un paquet de mesures contre la
fraude
par exemple la taxation d'office à 60 %
des sommes détenues à l'étranger non
justifiées mais aussi l'accès facilité
relevés bancaires des contribuables qui
ont omis de déclarer des comptes
bancaires ou des contrats d'assurance
vie à l'étranger et de tout cela nous
tirions et nous tirons un objectif c'est
d'accroître sa a été votée d'ailleurs
d'un milliard le rendement de l'action
des services fiscaux au moyen de ces
nouveaux dispositifs
il faudra aller plus loin et vos
propositions il contribue évidemment je
pense à la lutte contre le blanchiment
qui est fondamental dans le cadre de la
loi bancaire
nous avons pris vous étiez là je m'en
souviens fort bien une décision forte
s'agissant des paradis fiscaux président
la république a annoncé hier qu'il
souhaitait que ce soit étendu non
seulement aux banques mais à l'ensemble
des entreprises et il faudra encore
aller plus loin je pense aux révélations
dites off off shore links qui montrent
d'ailleurs que les paradis fiscaux
c'était loin d'être terminée
contrairement à ce que disait un ancien
président de la république et dans le
cadre européen
je veux agir pour aller dans ce sens-là
concernant le secret bancaire qui est un
sujet sur lequel vous vous êtes
également penché on voit bien qu'il est
en train de chanceler qu'il est attaqué
de tous côtés et à juste titre les
initiatives que j'ai pu prendre avec mes
collègues ministres des finances des
principaux pays de l'union européenne
vont dans ce sens elles ont déjà reçu
appui du commissaire en charge le
commissaire semeta
mais pas seulement de lui et je constate
qu'il ya des mouvements qui se font déjà
au luxembourg ou en autriche pays qui
ont été extrêmement restrictif et tout
ça débouche pour moi c'est la
proposition que j'ai faite la fatca
pardonnez moi cet acronyme européen
c'est un échange automatique
d'informations donc madame la sénatrice
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
nous tiendrons compte des travaux de la
haute assemblée pour aller plus loin
beaucoup plus loin dans cette lutte qui
doit être collective est unanime contre
l'évasion fiscale
merci la parole à françois marc pour le
groupe socialiste apparentés
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à pierre
moscovici milices de l'économie et des
finances dans une de ses déclarations
définitives dont il était coutumier
nicolas sarkozy avait annoncé le 24
septembre 2009 à la veille du sommet du
g20 à pittsburgh
je le cite je le cite écouter mes chers
collègues
écoutez bien monsieur sarkozy avait dit
les paradis fiscaux le secret bancaire
c'est terminé
près de quatre ans après il est
aujourd'hui clairement établie en
particulier après la publication par la
presse des listes de comptes off shore
que cet optimisme était sinon trompeur
du moins prématurée parce que le poids
des paradis fiscaux restent
considérables
plus de mille milliards d'euros sont
perdus chaque année dans l'union
européenne en raison de la fraude et
l'évasion fiscale il faut le dire avec
force le secret bancaire et les paradis
fiscaux sont le cancer de l'économie
mondiale et il y a incontestablement
urgence à agir
c'est dans cet esprit mes chers
collègues c'est dans cet esprit que le
jeudi 21 mars dernier le sénat a lors de
l'examen du projet de loi bancaire durci
les obligations de transparence des
banques aient voté un alourdissement des
sanctions
on doit bien sûr se félicité de la
détermination du président françois
hollande et de gouvernement à agir vite
sur ces questions vous avez vous même
pris le problème à bras le corps
monsieur le ministre en enjoignant vous
l'avez rappelé tout à l'heure au
commissaire européen à la fiscalité avec
vos collègues allemands britanniques
italiens et espagnols de mettre en place
un échange automatique d'informations
bancaires entre les pays membres de
l'union européenne
alors que va-t-il se passer à présent
à quelle échéance quels pays seront
concernés
une action de l'union européenne sur le
modèle à l'américaine dit fatca qui
imposera à toutes les banques du monde
divulguer les comptes détenus par des
citoyens américains va-t-elle être
entreprises
la france et ses partenaires pourront
ils engager un tel processus rapidement
monsieur le ministre sous la législature
précédente
on a beaucoup parlé des paradis fiscaux
mais on a très peu agi il est nécessaire
à présent de renverser la table
de quels moyens disposent en nous pour
le faire
merci monsieur pierre moscovici monsieur
le rapporteur général
votre question l'occasion pour moi de
présenter de manière un peu plus
détaillé les mesures qui ont été
annoncées hier par le président de la
république
en effet contrairement à ce qui avait
été affirmé avec un peu de précipitation
disons les paradis fiscaux ce n'est pas
fini et quand on voit au contraire la
publication de ces listes offshore leaks
on voit qu'il ya encore des conditions
fiscales beaucoup trop avantageuse et
l'existence d'un secret bancaire
beaucoup trop épais dans un certain
nombre de pays et tous ces événements
nous incite à agir davantage encore des
mesures portent je le rappelais ont été
prises dès le changement de majorité des
le collectif de l'été 2012 contre
l'évasion fiscale des entreprises
je viens de les mentionner en réponse à
madame goulet comme vous le savez et ça
c'est un point que votre assemblée a pu
marquer avec beaucoup de force
une disposition qui figure dans le
projet de loi de séparation et de
régulation des activités bancaires que
vous avez adopté récemment va apporter
une réponse forte et quand je dis forte
jeudi unique et quand je dis unique
jeudi unique au monde c'est à dire
qu'elle prévoit que les banques
françaises devront rendre public chaque
année la liste toutes leurs filiales
partout dans le monde par pays par pays
ainsi que leurs activités
l'ensemble de ces informations seront
publiques elles seront divulgués aussi
aux ong dont le rôle est très important
dans ce champ là mais il faudra aller
plus loin c'est ce qu'a dit le président
de la république et faire en sorte que
ce soit aussi valable pour les
entreprises aller plus loin ça veut dire
aussi prendre les mesures nécessaires
pour mettre fin au secret bancaire et je
veux amende est évidemment dans votre
sens à nouveau nous sommes aujourd'hui
un système où il ya les échanges qui
sont à la demande et si tout à l'heure
monsieur marini voulait dire qu'il ya
encore trop de secret bancaire que les
coopérations internationales sont trop
difficiles ou que les conventions sont
trop peu efficace surtout quand on est
restreint je suis d'accord c'est pour ça
qu'il faut substituer à ce système un
système d'entrée automatiques des
changes
un thomas tic c'est ce que j'ai déjà
proposé c'est ce que l'union européenne
j'en suis sûr
à part adopté enfin autre action
essentielle la liste des paradis fiscaux
fixé chaque année par le gouvernement
sera revue non plus seulement
fonctionnent la signature de la
convention d'échangé d'informations mais
aussi en s'attachant à la réalité de
leur évaluation pays par pays et le
président la république a dit à quel
point il était ferme sur ces questions
l'objectif il est clair et je leur dis
devant vous non les paradis fiscaux
c'est pas fini et dès lors que c'est pas
fini c'est à dire que lutter contre les
paradis fiscaux
c'est un combat mais ce combat la france
le mènera le mènera dans le cadre
français dans le cadre européen dans le
cadre international et avec la volonté
qui nous anime nous le gagnerons merci
la parole à monsieur albéric de
montgolfier pour le groupe un peu merci
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à madame
la ministre chargé de la
décentralisation et elle porte bien
évidemment bien évidemment sur le projet
de loi de réforme des collectivités et
également sur ses conséquences sur nos
budgets locaux puisque face aux
multiples protestations dans les rangs
de la majorité mais également à la
proche de quelques échéances électorales
le gouvernement a décidé lors du conseil
des ministres d'hier de scinder le
projet le premier projet en trois textes
qui portent respectivement sur les
métropoles sur les régions et sur les
solidarités territoriales ce
saucissonnage du texte soit des ans
tradition est critiqué sur de nombreux
rangs y compris par le président de la
commission des lois que je vois ici et
je le cite qui dénonçait dès le premier
projet un objet législatif allant dans
tous les sens et accordant des
compétences à géométrie variable et
qu'il regrettait le seul président la
semaine dernière qu'ils regrettaient sur
ses bancs la semaine dernière ce
découpage ces trois textes à cordes
madame la ministre la priorité dans le
cadre des prix alimentaires une priorité
aux métropoles nos communes nos
départements seront donc évoqué en
dernier madame la ministre
en donnant la priorité aux métropoles et
aux grandes agglomérations vous risquez
de faire reposer le développement du
pays
sur le seul fait urbain
l'assemblée des départements de france
qui est d'ailleurs présidé par un élu de
votre majorité condamne à theix là aussi
citation qui considère ce territoire
comme un sujet annexe
par ailleurs le gouvernement a annoncé
la baisse des dotations 4 milliards 500
millions d'euros auxquels il faut
ajouter 7 à une estimation la dgcl 802
millions d'euros deux mois pour au titre
des normes 1 go de travail du comité des
finances locales s'est d'ailleurs réuni
au sénat ce matin mais pour évoquer
cette question mais comment répondre à
cette question de la baisse des
dotations alors même que nous ne
connaissons pas ce stade les futures
compétences comme l'a très justement
souligné eric doligé mon voisin
aujourd'hui le premier texte à étudier
aurait dû être celui de la clarification
et de la simplification des compétences
alors que les élus locaux avaient
condamné c'était le cas dans les états
généraux la décentralisation avait
condamné la complexification croissante
des textes quelle est la cohérence du
séquençage de cette nouvelle réforme
comment nos concitoyens comment les élus
peuvent-ils comprendre les annonces
multiples parfois contradictoires du
gouvernement qu'elle est enfin le
calendrier exact de la réforme de ces
textes et en particulier le calendrier
de l'examen du dernier texte qui sera
consacré aux communes et aux
départements
madame la ministre je crois que les élus
ont besoin de clarté merci madame anne
marie escoffier ministre chargé de la
décentralisation
monsieur le président monsieur le
sénateur de montgolfier les questions la
question que vous venez de me poser me
donne l'occasion de vous apporter des
réponses aussi précise que possible sur
l'état des travaux que nous avons
conduit d'abord peut-être préciser que
la volonté du gouvernement une volonté
affirmée déterminé c'est d'aller vers un
texte qui soit un texte de clarification
un texte d'efficacité un texte de
maîtrise des dépenses
trois objectifs que nous avons inscrit
dans ce texte
avec la volonté de toujours le faire
dans le cadre d'une véritable
concertation d'un vrai dialogue que nous
avons voulu avec vous dans le cadre des
états généraux de la démocratie
territoriale mais aussi avec l'ensemble
de nos élus partenaires et qui nous ont
apporté des éclairages tout à fait
indispensable alors le texte qui a été
présenté en conseil des ministres vous
dites saucissonné monsieur le sénateur
non je ne reprendrai pas le mot je dis
que nous avons un texte unique un texte
qui est un vrai pacte impact de la
démocratie impact de décentralisation et
de réforme de l'action publique qui ne
dissocie pas les collectivités
territoriales de l'état mais qui apporte
cette cohérence indispensable pour que
l'action publique tout en ensemble est
un véritable sens pour les citoyens un
texte dont donc jeudi de clarification
efficacité de maîtrise des dépenses
j'y viens parce que la maîtrise des
dépenses est un objectif auquel nous
sommes tous attachés
nous avons dit l'effort et toutes les
collectivités ont accepté de participer
à cet effort lors d'une réunion tenue
par le premier ministre le 12 mars
dernier une réunion au cours de laquelle
nous avons inscrit les principes d'un
pacte de confiance et de responsabilité
pacte que nous écrirons ensemble et qui
permettra de mesurer dans les dotations
comment faire les économies qu'ils
doivent être des économies à hauteur de
1 milliard 500 millions c'est vrai pour
l'année 2014
repris en 2015 un effort sur lequel nous
essaierons de faire de faire peser sur
l'ensemble des collectivités
territoriales en veillant à ce que la
péréquation servent l'intérêt des moins
des vagues des moins favorisés par
rapport aux plus favorisés
rien ne nous échappera dans ce travail
sur les dotations ni sur la péréquation
ni sur la fiscalité je veux vous assurer
en tout cas de la détermination très
fort qui est la nôtre de faire en sorte
que les textes que nous attendons et
dont nous avons besoin puissent
intervenir dans tous les cas c'est notre
objectif avant les élections prochaines
de l'année 2014 pour le premier et le
deuxième texte
il nous faut y parvenir avant la fin de
cette année voilà les silences que je
voulais vous apportez monsieur le sénat
merci la parole à madame christiane
demontès pour le groupe socialiste
monsieur le président mesdames les
ministres messieurs les ministres mes
chers collègues ma question s'adresse à
monsieur michel sapin ministre du
travail de l'emploi de la formation
professionnelle et du dialogue social
monsieur le ministre la crise économique
que nous traversons est grave très grave
avec ses conséquences avec ses
conséquences sur la destruction
d'emplois
des centaines de milliers d'emplois ont
été détruits
et puis son corollaire les chômeurs
l'augmentation du chômage tend plus de 3
millions de personnes aujourd'hui en
france ne travaillent pas du tout dont
plus de la moitié qui sont au chômage de
longue durée c'est à dire depuis plus
d'un an après l'action ou plutôt
l'inaction en faveur de l'emploi du
précédent gouvernement
je le rappelle qui promet qui prônait le
travailler plus pour gagner plus avec
ses conséquences en matière d'injustice
entre ceux qui avaient un travail et
ceux qui n'en avaient pas vous avez
décidé sous la responsabilité du
président de la république de travail et
d'agir pour le travail pour tous nos
présidents de la république a fait de la
lutte contre l'emploi sa priorité la
priorité nationale
vous savez monsieur le ministre avec
l'ensemble du gouvernement décidé de
mettre en oeuvre un certain nombre
d'actions pour justement lutter en
faveur du travail et contre le chômage
vous l'avez fait avec une méthode la
méthode du dialogue social un certain
nombre de mesures ont déjà été prises
les emplois d'avenir pour favoriser
l'accès au travail des jeunes sans
qualification
les contrats de génération pour
permettre aux entreprises de recruter
des jeunes en cdi
tout en maintenant dans l'emploi des
travailleurs âgés nous travaillons
aujourd'hui sur la sécurisation des
parcours professionnels
la sécurisation de l'emploi nous aurons
l'occasion d'y revenir la semaine
prochaine pour autant monsieur le
ministre le chômage ne se résorbe pas
comme ça nous avons toujours plus de 3
millions de chômeurs vous avez décidé
est le premier ministre nous l'a dit
vous avez décidé de recruter davantage
d'agents du service public de l'emploi
est particulièrement à pôle emploi
pouvez vous nous dire monsieur le
ministre comment auront lieu ces
recrutements à quel moment et surtout et
je pense que ça intéresse l'ensemble
maître de mes collègues sénateurs
comment vous allez répartir ces agents
recrutés sur l'ensemble du territoire
merci ou répondre au plus près aux
besoins de nos concitoyens
monsieur michel sapin ministre du
travail de l'emploi de la formation
professionnelle
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs et sénatrices
madame la sénatrice
je ne reviendrai pas les français le
connaissent mais ne vivent tous les
jours sur les désastres que provoque
socialement cette accumulation depuis
plus de cinq ans mois après mois de
l'augmentation du nombre des chômeurs il
faut agir nous le faisons nous le
faisons avec des outils nouveaux les
emplois d'avenir
pour les jeunes sans emploi sans
formation cinq cent mille jeunes sans
emploi sans formation
jamais la république ne l'avait connu
c'était de votre temps nous agissons
le contrat de génération vous l'avez
décrit aider un jeune à rentrer dans une
entreprise quelle que soit sa
qualification tout en utilisant
l'intelligence l'expérience la capacité
de transmettre son savoir du plus âgé
qui lui aussi restera dans l'entreprise
en question la loi sur la sécurisation
de l'emploi qui sera bonne pour l'emploi
est mauvaise pour les licenciements et
dont nous aurons à discuter ici point
par point et j'attends beaucoup de ses
explications pour permettre à ceux qui
n'auraient pas encore compris tous les
éléments de progrès de cette loi de les
apprécier et à partir de là de les
soutenir
et puis madame vous avez raison de
parler de cette grande de ce grand
service public le service public de
l'emploi
parce que qu'ils rencontrent le chômeur
qui en face de lui le drame qui a en
face de lui
celui ou celle qui cherche une
explication une recommandation une
information ce sont ces hommes et ces
femmes qui sont là dans les agences de
pôle emploi qui vivent au quotidien les
difficultés des chômeurs et qui leur
apporte des solutions concrètes moi je
veux leur rendre hommage
je veux leur dire que grâce à eux pour
un grand nombre de chômeurs il y a des
solutions et qu'il supporte aussi par
ailleurs les difficultés que ces
chômeurs peuvent vivre dans leur vie
quotidienne
oui le gouvernement a décidé l'année
dernière
laudun d'autoriser pôle emploi embauché
deux mille emplois supplémentaires en
contrat à durée indéterminée alors que
vous en aviez détruit 1800 dans les
années qui ont précédé
nous avons considéré qu'il fallait
renforcer encore ses moyens cette année
nous avons autorisé le premier ministre
a autorisé la création de 2000 emplois
supplémentaires
ça fait 2 plus de 4 et pôle emploi fait
un effort sur lui-même pour faire en
sorte qu'un certain nombre d'emplois qui
était dans l'administration soit tourné
vers chacun des chômeurs ce sont donc
six mille personnes de plus qui vont
enfin pouvoir rencontrer les chômeurs et
apporter des solutions tenter de leur
apporter des solutions
ce sont plus de 20 % d'augmentation
effectifs de pôle emploi au contact avec
les chômeurs oui ça passe aussi par ça
la bataille pour l'emploi la bataille
contre le chômage
la diminution du nombre des chômeurs ce
que nous obtiendrons d'ici la fin de
cette année ça passe aussi par le
dévouement des hommes et des femmes qui
au sein de pôle emploi font face aux
difficultés si et apporter des solutions
merci la parole est à présent monsieur
gérard cornu pour le groupe ump
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à arnaud
montebourg ministre du redressement
productif
monsieur le ministre chaque jour notre
pays s'enfonce un peu plus dans la crise
une crise économique d'abord mais aussi
morale alors que la république
exemplaire promise par le président
hollande a vécu est enterré dans les
conditions calamiteuses que l'on sait
alors que le sénat débat depuis des
jours sur un sujet dit du mariage pour
tout ce qui divise les français et dont
l'urgente nécessité continuent
d'échapper au plus grand nombre
j'ai envie de vous poser la question
essentielle où va l'économie française
pendant ce temps en effet les dernières
prévisions passées inaperçues traduit
une réalité économique alarmante
croissance zéro en 2014 déficit
budgétaire de quatre et demi pourcent
endettement proche de 100% du pib'
déficit extérieur et chômage accru et
cela sans aucune garantie de reprise en
2015 que fait le gouvernement
après arcelormittal et l'arrêt des hauts
fourneaux de florange décidé en ce
moment lundi c'est l'équipementier
automobile heuliez qui annonçait son
dépôt de bilan
280 emplois sont menacés on apprend ce
matin
que le lien est placée en redressement
judiciaire un sursis cette affaire en
tout cas dans un secteur très durement
touché par la crise est exemplaire hélas
pour ne pas dire symbolique de
l'incapacité de ce gouvernement à
apporter des réponses efficaces à des
réalités économiques qu'il ne connaît
pas et auquel il tente d'appliquer des
solutions idéologique
monsieur le ministre on ne peut vouloir
tout et son contraire d'accès et
décourager les automobilistes et en même
temps se plaindre que la filière
automobile va mal il faut être cohérent
au-delà du cas heuliez ce sont de
nombreuses petites entreprises sous
traitantes qu'on appelle les équipes
entier de deuxième rang qui irrigue
l'ensemble de notre territoire et qui
souffrent par manque de commandes et
donc de travail
ces petits patrons n'en peuvent plus et
toute la filière est en danger
la précédente majorité avaient mis en
place des mécanismes de soutien avec
raison et lucidité la question s'il vous
plaît pouvez vous nous préciser les
actions que vous entendez mener pour
préserver non seulement oliech mais
aussi toute la filière automobile
très bien merci la parole à monsieur
montebourg ministre du redressement
productif
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs dessus le
sénateur cornu vous évoquez la filière
automobile et vous évoquez à juste titre
sur un point le cas de ces entreprises
invisible celle dont on ne parle pas qui
ne sont pas les constructeurs donneurs
d'ordre qui sont dans nos territoires et
qui subissent par contre coup les
affaiblissements de marché
ce n'est pas seulement la france c'est
toute l'europe c'est une question
européenne - 16 en espagne - 20 en
france - 22 en italie
même en allemagne nous sommes à moins 5
le seul endroit où cela progresse et au
royaume uni
mais partout ailleurs et
particulièrement dans les pays de la
zone euro les affaissements de commandes
la diminution de la consommation il est
général et structurelles et les
questions de taxation que vous évoquez
n'y sont d'ailleurs pas corrélés qu'est
ce que le gouvernement fait d'abord des
mesures d'urgence je voudrais vous
donner quelques exemples de la façon
dont nous organisons le sauvetage
non pas pour le sauvetage mais parce que
nous voulons préserver nos outils
industriels nos savoir-faire nos
technologies nos ingénieurs autant que
nous le pouvons
et tout le monde accepte autour de la
table le ciri les commissaires
redressement productif dans les
préfectures des sacrifices bien sûr les
salariés les premiers qui perdent leur
emploi
pas tous nous essayons donc conserver le
plus possible les actionnaires l'état
qui abandonnent une partie des créances
les créanciers qui en abandonne aussi et
nous faisons finalement face pour
maintenir notre tissu industriel c'est
notre stratégie à l'allemande
je prends quelques exemples de succès si
lynx à charleval dans l'eure
nous avons sauvé avec les constructeurs
mbf technologies dans le haut jura
nous avons sauvé la fonderie d'aluminium
qui était menacée de disparition
c'est un succès avec les constructeurs
je veux parler de sora dans le
loir-et-cher l'ille-et-vilaine la
mayenne 500 emplois préservés racheté
par faurecia avec des équipementiers de
rang 1
c'est un travail au cas par cas nous
connaissons des succès parfois des
échecs parfois des deux me succès ou des
deux mis ses échecs
alors monsieur le sénateur maintenant
vous évoquer les questions macro
économie d'ordre général bien sûr nous
nous battons pour la réorientation
l'union européenne ce qu'a dit le
président de la république pour la
croissance
nous avons été élus pour cela parce que
précisément nous avons connu la
récession pendant cinq ans et vous qui
ne semblait pas vouloir louer les
efforts du gouvernement
je voudrais vous dire monsieur le
sénateur que les 600 milliards de
est que nous avons à rembourser elles ne
sont pas tombés par l'opération de la
sainte vierge
elles sont tombés parce qu'il ya des
gens qui ont vécu au-dessus de leurs
moyens et je crains que vous ayez
soutenu certains gouvernements qu'ils
aient commis quelques abus en la matière
un million de chômeurs de plus en cinq
ans 600 milliards de dettes de plus en
cinq ans 70 milliards de déficit du
commerce sciences accord monsieur le
sénateur la modestie pourrait être la
manière d'aborder les sujets qui nous
sont comme merci merci la parole à
madame catherine tasca pour le groupe
socialiste
monsieur le président mesdames messieurs
les ministres madame la ministre de la
culture depuis plus de deux décennies
l'exemption culturel est un principe
fondamental de la politique culturelle
de la france que nous avons constamment
soutenu de ce côté-ci de l'hémicycle
l'expression souvent de regarder et
qualifié de ligne maginot ne vise
évidemment pas à affirmer une quelconque
supériorité de la culture française
elle exprime la volonté politique de
faire en sorte que les productions
culturelles les oeuvres de l'esprit ne
sont pas des marchandises comme les
autres et ne peuvent pas être soumises
aux seules règles du marché
ce principe s'est imposé dès
l'après-guerre pour le cinéma avec la
création du cnc outils de soutien à la
production originale française face à la
toute-puissance du cinéma américain
depuis cette nécessité a été reconnu
bien au-delà de nos frontières la france
avec les autres pays francophones a joué
un rôle moteur dans l'adoption par
l'unesco en 2005 de la convention sur la
diversité culturelle
jusqu'ici jamais l'union européenne n'a
mis en cause cette exception aujourd'hui
s'annonce à l'initiative de la
commission guidé par une vision
ultralibérale du marché
la négociation d'un accord de libre
échange entre les états unis et l'union
européenne qui pour la première fois
n'exclurait pas de son nom d'anne
négociations les biens et services
culturels
quand on sait que l'industrie
cinématographique et audiovisuelle
américaine n'a pas cessé de contester
nos réglementations en la matière tous
ceux qui sont attachés à l'identité
culturelle à la vitalité de la création
originale autant qu'à son poids
économique en termes d'emploi ne peuvent
éprouver une grande inquiétude et une
indignation devant cette initiative de
la commission
fort heureusement le président de la
république et le gouvernement
par votre voix madame la ministre est
celle de la ministre du commerce
extérieur madame nicole bricq qui sera
en première ligne pour cette négociation
ont affirmé sans réserve leur opposition
à toute tentative de réintroduire
l'audiovisuel dans un accord de libre
échange
face à la nouvelle donne du
développement d'internet et du numérique
madame la ministre
pouvez vous nous dire quelle place tient
l'exception culturelle dans votre
politique et quelles initiatives vous
comptez prendre avec vos collègues
européens pour barrer l'initiative
funeste de la commission merci encore le
madame ton reliques une petit ministre
de la culture de la communication madame
monsieur le président madame la
sénatrice catherine tasca
vous l'avez dit avec nicole bricq nous
sommes fortement mobilisés contre ce
projet funeste de la commission
européenne de revenir sur une position
solide stable
vieille de 20 ans au minimum du temps
des premiers accords du gatt sous la
présidence de françois mitterrand
ce principe il est partagé largement sur
ce sur ses bancs c'est celui de
l'exception culturelle
ce principe de l'exception culturelle ce
n'est pas une exception culturelle
française c'est la préservation de
mécanismes de financement de la culture
et en particulier de l'audiovisuel
qui permettent d'échapper à la seule loi
du marché qui parle qui permettent
d'échapper à la seule loi de la libre
concurrence
parce que les produits culturels les
produits audiovisuels ne sont pas des
marchandises comme des autres vous
l'avez dit il véhicule une vision du
monde
il véhicule une vision de la société ce
sont des instruments aussi de puissance
de rayonnement
et puis il faut le dire il faut le
rappeler parce que trop souvent c'est
sous-estimer
ils sont facteurs de croissance et créer
des emplois en france et en europe
la commission européenne elle même pas
plus tard que la semaine dernière a
sorti une étude qui indique que plus de
3 3% du pib européen provient des
industries culturelles et 3% des emplois
alors ne laissons pas notre marché
ouvert à tous les vents et en
particulier aux vents venus des états
unis
bien sûr nous aimons le cinéma américain
mais nous n'avons pas envie d'être
envahi par des productions
audiovisuelles américaine qui pourrait
être bradés sur nos marchés
pour la simple et bonne raison qu'elles
sont déjà amortis sur le marché
américain
ce serait extrêmement dangereux pour
l'ensemble de nos concitoyens
extrêmement dangereux pour les citoyens
européens qui sont attachés à un
principe aussi c'est celui de la
diversité culturelle car l'exception
culturelle et un est au service de la
diversité culturelle et donc le
président de la république l'a dit l'a
affirmé averses avec force il ne
laissera pas la commission européenne
brader ce printemps ce principe
essentiel celui de l'exception
culturelle et dans le cadre des
négociations qui s'ouvrent entre l'union
européenne et les etats unis
il est hors de question que la france
revienne sur ce qui fait le coeur de sa
conception et de sa vision du monde et
de la société
ce principe de l'exception culturelle
nous avons pour cela le soutien des
parlementaires dont vous faites partie
l'assemblée nationale comme le sénat et
l'assemblée va prendre une proposition
de résolution sur ce sujet qui va nous
permettre à nicole bricq et à moi même
d'être encore renforcée dans nos
positions vis-à-vis de nos collègues
européens
nicole bricq portera cette position lors
des discussions et et moi même
là je la porterai lors du conseil des
ministres européens de la culture au
mois de mai je vous remercie de votre
soutien merci le chers collègues nous en
avons fini avec les questions
d'actualité au gouvernement je veux
suspendre la séance
voilà donc pour cette séance des
questions d'actualité au gouvernement
on se retrouve tout de suite avec nos
invités pour refaire ensemble la séance
1 on refait la séance après les
questions d'actualité au gouvernement
une séance particulièrement agitée ici
au sénat c'est rare de voir une ambiance
aussi tendu électrique à la haute
assemblée
il faut dire que peut-être les débats
autour du projet de loi mariage pour
tous ses biens électrise un peu les
esprits ici au sénat en tout cas on va
en parler avec nos premiers